Ayudamos a las comunidades a construir letrinas,
y les enseñamos a separar sus animales de sus viviendas
para reducir la cantidad de moscas.
Así que sabemos cómo atacar la enfermedad.
Pero tenemos que saber dónde está.
Y lo sabemos,
porque Sightsavers, hace unos años, llevó a cabo un programa increíble
que se llamó Proyecto Mundial de Mapeo del Tracoma.
Nos llevó tres años,
pero fuimos a 29 países,
formando trabajadores de la salud locales, que luego fueron distrito por distrito
y examinaron los párpados de más de 2,5 millones de personas.
Usaron teléfonos Android para descargar los datos.
Y a partir de eso pudimos trazar un mapa
para ver dónde estaba la enfermedad.
Este es un mapa muy general
que muestra los países donde el tracoma era endémico.
Uds. podrían preguntarme: "¿Funciona realmente esta estrategia?"
Sí, funciona.
Este mapa muestra el progreso que hemos hecho hasta ahora.
Los países en verde consideran que han eliminado el tracoma,
y ya han obtenido, o están en proceso de obtener,
la validación de la OMS.
Los países en amarillo tienen el dinero que necesitan,
tienen los recursos para eliminar el tracoma.
Y algunos están muy cerca de lograrlo.
Pero los países en rojo no tienen suficientes fondos.
No pueden eliminar el tracoma a menos que consigan más.
Y nos preocupa mucho que se frene el progreso hecho hasta ahora.
Entonces, mientras hablábamos con el equipo de Audacious,
nos preguntamos:
Si nos esforzáramos mucho, pero mucho, durante los próximos cuatro o cinco años,
y si tuviéramos el dinero,
¿qué pensamos que podríamos conseguir?
Bueno, creemos que podemos eliminar el tracoma
en 12 países africanos
y en toda América
y en todo el Pacífico.
Y podemos hacer un progreso importante
en los dos países donde la enfermedad pesa más:
Etiopía y Nigeria.
Y haciendo todo eso,
podemos aprovechar más USD 2000 millones en donaciones de medicamentos.
(Aplausos)
Este mapa les muestra el impacto que vamos a tener...
fíjense cuántos países pasaron al verde.
Y ahí pueden ver el progreso en Etiopía y en Nigeria.
Es verdad, todavía quedan algunos países en rojo.
Son principalmente países en conflicto,
países como Yemen, Sudán del Sur, donde es muy difícil trabajar.
Entonces, tenemos el equipo, la estrategia y el mapa.
Y también tenemos los contactos a nivel gubernamental
para coordinar nuestro programa
con otros programas de control de enfermedades
de un modo eficiente.
¿No sería increíble si pudiéramos hacer esto?
Tendríamos al tracoma en retirada.
Estaríamos en la recta final
para eliminar la enfermedad en todo el mundo.
Pero, antes de terminar, quisiera compartir con Uds.
unas palabras del fundador de Sightsavers,
un hombre llamado Sir John Wilson.
Él se quedó ciego a los 12 años.
Y dijo:
"Un millón de personas no se quedan ciegas al mismo tiempo.
Se quedan ciegas una por una".
Y en el entusiasmo de poder decir
que eliminamos el tracoma en todo el país,
no nos olvidemos que, en realidad, esta es una enfermedad devastadora
que le destruye la vida a cada persona.
Personas como Twiba.
Conocí a Twiba el año pasado en Tanzania.
Ella había tenido tracoma desde que tenía memoria.
Y se operó un par de meses antes de que yo la conociera.
No exagero cuando digo
que la operación le había transformado totalmente la vida.
Habíamos salvado la visión que le quedaba y ya no tenía más dolor.
Podía dormir.
Podía trabajar, podía socializar.
Y me dijo:
"He recuperado mi vida".
Fue imposible no conmoverme con la historia de esa mujer.
Pero hay muchas Twibas.
Yo quiero encontrar a todas las Twibas,
y no quiero que nadie más se quede ciego en el dolor, nunca más.
¿Saben qué? Hay muchos problemas intratables en el mundo.
Pero este no es uno de ellos.
Esto es algo que podemos solucionar.
Y podemos asegurarnos
de que niños como estos puedan crecer sin miedo al tracoma.
Así que, por los niños como estos,
y por las personas como Twiba,
eliminemos el tracoma.
¿Piensan que podemos hacerlo?
Bueno, si realmente lo queremos, sí.
Sí, podemos.
Así que gracias.
(Aplausos)